and let's start right there because the
san francisco
49ers have made it halfway through their
schedule
unbeaten who would have thought that the
49ers would be 8-0 they were four and 12
last year they've doubled their wins in
half the number of games and last night
and and this is where
you can
spin it in a very positive way if you're
a 49ers fan
last night was one of those games that
they had to fight
and scratch and claw to win
this will serve them well
down the road when they get themselves
in a game where they have to fight and
scratch and claw to win because
they did it the muscle memory if there's
any relevance to that cliche whatsoever
in this setting it will be there
they won't freak out they've been in
some tough spots they know what it takes
they know how to stay calm under fire if
you're beating everybody by 40 points
and then all of a sudden you find
yourself in a close game you may not
know what to do i think there is
something to that it sounds a little
trite but i think there is something to
it
so if there is good for the 49ers
because they had a tough game they had a
rough outing but they ended up winning
defensively think about this they had
allowed 17 points week one to the
buccaneers 17 points week two to the
bengals 20 points week three to the
steelers and then after the buy four
weeks combined the 49ers defense allowed
a total
of 23 points last night
25 points were given up by the san
francisco 49ers and we've got the post
to pro footballtalk.com with the quotes
from richard sherman
uncharacteristically humbled was richard
sherman in the aftermath of the game in
part because there was an 88-yard
touchdown late in the contest that
ultimately narrowed the gap to three
points kyler murray to fellow rookie
andy isabella 88-yard catch and run
there were some failures of basic
fundamental tackling that allowed andy
isabella to turn that into a touchdown
and richard sherman humbled by that the
defense humbled by the performance but
the 49ers victorious see that's what's
great and that's a hallmark of a great
team when you can win
even on a night that is far from your
best night that's a special season
that's the kind of thing you point to
and say we're on to something here
because even though we're completely
unhappy with how we played defensively
we still won the game and they won the
game in large part due to a great
performance from quarterback jimmy
garoppolo
28 of 37 317 yards
four touchdowns no interceptions an
early case for
nfc offensive player of the week pending
the results of all of the games but it's
hard to imagine anyone having a better
week and i've said at some point jimmy
garoppolo is going to have to step up
and make a big throw in a big spot in a
big game he made multiple big throws he
made multiple drive sustaining throws
and there was a key moment at the end of
the first half before i
tell you that let me let me just point
out
how rare of the performance was that we
saw last night from garoppolo first four
touchdown past performance for the 49ers
since colin kaepernick december of 2012
when he took the 49ers into foxboro and
they beat the patriots 41-34 on sunday
night football first time there's been a
49ers quarterback to have four touchdown
passes and 300 more passing yards since
jeff garcia in 2000 that's how long it's
been so garoppolo showing that he's more
than just a bystander to
a championship level defense and an
excellent running game garoppolo earning
his money last night now key exchange
late in the first half
49ers up 14-7
fourth and goal from the one four
seconds left
they come out they line up they snapped
the ball the cardinals stuffed the
running attempt
but you could hear the whistles blowing
the whistles were blowing not because
the 49ers had called a timeout not
because there was a delay of game not
because there was any penalty or
anything else the whistles were blowing
because cardinals coach cliff kingsbury
decided to take a time out
and
after the game he took responsibility
for it he said he wanted to get a look
at what they were going to do he wanted
them to burn their best play for that
spot
and if that was their best play well
they were wrong it was a better play
because that play didn't score the next
play did it was a touchdown pass from
jimmy garoppolo to emmanuel sanders and
emmanuel sanders has been
a great addition he's the guy they
traded for last week third round pick
plus one of those little back end you
give us a five we'll give you a four to
make it look like it's actually being
evened out it basically is a third round
pick
that's a lot to give up for a 32
32 year old receiver who had a torn
achilles tendon late last season but you
know what he's been spectacular so far
and it's just it's clicking now the
passing game is clicking they already
had george kittle need to be a little
worried about him he left the game late
he was on the sidelines he wasn't there
for the final two drives had a knee
injury early kyle shanahan the coach of
the team said after the game that it was
a knee and ankle problem for george
kittle and he did gut it out he had a 30
yard
catch and run for a touchdown after that
knee injury and you could see him take a
helmet to the knee if you're watching on
tv it's one of those moments where the
knee goes in a direction that the knee
is not supposed to go and it looked a
little
serious at first it was surprising to
see him back out there so soon but late
in the game he was standing on the
sidelines and so that's a situation
where he'll get checked out and they may
have to hold their breath a little bit
but they have fought through injury
they're going to get some of their
injured guys back kyle yuschik will be
back for the monday night game most
likely coming up in about 10 days
against the seattle seahawks and the
schedule does get more difficult for the
49ers last night was a nice test
and they're going to need to play better
defensively when they come up against
the seahawks week 10. they got the
cardinals again week 11. no gimme there
then the packers week 12. then two tough
road games at the ravens at the saints
then they get a a second bye week
essentially with a visit from the
falcons and then they wrap up with the
rams and at the seahawks so the second
half of the schedule a lot more
difficult than the first half of the
schedule and i'm not saying they won't
run the table but if they run the table
they will have earned it these next
eight games have multiple real
challenges for the 49ers but last night
again jimmy garoppolo steps up big spot
big moment gets it done
and he earns the praise of his coach
kyle shanahan here's shanahan talking
about garoppolo's performance after the
game
he played great today
he made a lot of plays in rhythm and
made a lot of off-schedule plays they
got a great pass rush they had some real
tight coverages they mixed up a lot of
stuff but
i thought jimmy played a hell of a game
and
his best game yet probably
calamari played a pretty good game for
the arizona cardinals as well he was 17
of 24 241 yards two touchdowns now 88 of
those yards came on that one play when
they were down 11
in the fourth quarter and there was
another questionable decision from cliff
kingsbury in the fourth quarter and look
hey he's he's new he's new at this right
freddy kitchens uses that excuse in
cleveland we'll we'll give that one a
cliff kingsbury in arizona you're kind
of learning how best to manage these
games at the nfl level and whether it's
getting that that premature look at what
the 49ers were doing on fourth and goal
from the one at the end of the half and
having it blow up in your face or
using a challenge right before the two
minute warning to look at a spot of a
ball on a third down run where tevin
coleman ran out of bounds and he was
given the first down yardage by the
officials on the field
and it's probably a situation where
cliff kingsbury should not have thrown
the red challenge flag because
it's not easy in any situation to have
the clear and obvious evidence necessary
to re-spot the ball when it's close like
that they're not going to re-spot the
ball and make it short of the first down
and that was a wasted challenge but more
importantly a wasted timeout they could
have used that timeout down the stretch
because eventually the 49ers were able
to just do the kneel down parade and get
out of arizona with the victory so look
the cardinals have many things they can
feel good about their three five and one
i didn't expect them to be that good but
they've had opportunities just in the
last week i mean they were three three
and one on sunday morning they played
the saints more closely than 31-9 would
indicate and then they gave the 49ers
everything they could handle they should
be proud there's no moral victories look
there's a little bit of a moral victory
here you're a team that is in the early
stages of trying to build something and
the 7-1 saints
had to
sweat it out until midway through the
third quarter before they began the
process of putting the cardinals away on
sunday and the 49ers had to sweat it out
for the whole game and i think the
cardinals should take some pride in the
fact that they were down 21-7 at the
half after that ill-advised decision to
take a time out on a play that
ultimately did not work for the 49ers
the second chance pushes it to 21-7 the
cardinals did not go away they continued
to come after the 49ers and they should
be proud of what they did there also
proud of a trade that they made
that has worked out pretty well kenyon
drake
three days
after being sent from miami to arizona
he had 162 total yards from scrimmage it
made people wonder what the heck is
miami doing maybe they are tanking trade
away all your great players 162 yards
from scrimmage looked like he's been
with the cardinals his whole career and
let me tell you something if this guy
continues to perform like that it's
going to raise some real questions about
what they do with david johnson's
contract because he's due to make over
10 million dollars next year on that
long-term contract he signed early 2018
and
hey dollars and cents rip the name off
the back of the jersey you got to be
smart about this 10.5 million is a lot
more than david johnson probably
deserves at this point given recent
performances and given given injury
history
kenyon drake may be staking his claim to
that job at least based on what we saw
last night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports